so here's a better proof and it's going
to work for all values of theta not just
any triangle but I think the Handy
triangle is really good for their buck
okay I'm gonna come back to these guys
these are double angle formulas are how
I got the T results in the first place
how I got these two algebraic
expressions is here somebody's the same
for sine right and for cosine so let's
do side first if I replace just like I
did before all the theaters with half
theatres all the things I'm going to get
on the left hand side 2 times 1/2 theta
which is just cleaned up and then I'm
gonna get 2 sine 1/2 theta cos 1/2 theta
ok now excuse me I need to get this all
in terms of tears need to get all in
terms of tens because that's what that's
what T is right so in order to get rid
of any sines and cosines of just have
T's flying around I've got to turn these
guys it's a tense how do I do it my
first step is I'm going to divide by 1
but instead of 1 I'm going to use the
path the choreography which is closed
squared plus sine squared ok of course I
could write cos squared theta and sine
theta
but I have everything else in terms of
feed on to so everything here is in
terms of the same angle which is why the
functions can relate to each other ok
now remember bless you where I'm headed
this is where I'm going ok so I'm going
to do one operation to take you from
here to there remember what these are
remember what these T's are there 10 huh
feeders so how do I get 10 huh feeders
appearing here what am I gonna do think
feed back to where we had equations in
terms of sines and cosines right what we
did in order to get things in terms of
10 right I'm gonna need to divide what
shall i /
I'm gonna do mine the top and the butter
right think about the top they go the
top if I divide the top by cause then
that cause would disappear right if I
divide by cause again then this side
will turn it to her ten right so I'll do
cos square right so if you divide the
top you better do mine that's what I
belong as well okay and now you can see
what's going to happen right what's good
at up here at the top to ten feet up on
to exactly what I want and then what
happens here of the denominator well
this guy is going to turn to one and
then this guy is going to turn it to
side squared on Cosco which is stands
where okay like that so there's the ten
half these that I laughed and that's 2t
on one plus t-squared okay see how it
worked so this is a more thorough way of
doing you see I didn't introduce any
triangles to prove this I just use
identities which I know which are always
true I think but it's a bit it's kind of
like why did you do that
like why did I divide by this cosine
because I wanted to and why did I divide
by this because I knew where I was
headed
already right so I think this is
generally a better way to remember it
this is a better way to prove it really
quickly and now that I've shown you how
did it with side you can help me do a
lot faster with cosine what do you think
my first step should be
yeah good I'll change everything in
terms of theatres or twos on here and
these heat so I'll divide all the
theaters my students words so have this
okay remember I want to get things in
terms of tears right so what a trick
what truth did not employ here on my
first slide with sign I divided by one
but I'll divide by one in a helpful way
rather than a boring way so that's kind
of helpful right and then what did I do
next yeah I'm gonna turn all of these
closed squares into ones and all of a
sine Squared's into tan square divided
by cos squared squared you can see you
literally just falls out get exactly the
same way that side does right I'm gonna
get one minus
geez okay so excuse me this is a great
little result this is the proper proof
but I'm gonna recommend just like you
know one of the first things you might
do when you sit down and you start
through your paper which has any kind of
trick involved in it you might draw one
of these right like so I know someone 19
right okay exact values I know that say
30 is 1/2 and that makes this side root
3 okay
just like that's a useful tool for a
remember your exact values this is a
useful tool for a memory all of the T
results in the right corner because you
can just redeposit an alphabet okay so
I'm going to say because the first time
I did it I started with this started
with this right but I wanted to turn all
of these sines and cosines into tears
okay and I knew that I was gonna have a
1 plus 10 squared or the denominator
okay but I don't even have a denominator
here okay so I kind of knew in advance I
need to introduce one but I can't just
introduce like I'm gonna divide by 3 or
4 or 5 because that would actually
change this so I divided by 1 because
dividing by 1 doesn't change things
right so divided by 1 it's still the
same identity right I don't change this
value but having introduced these it
gives me a kind of bridge to get to this
helpful web ok